which of your friends and family were
the most excited that you got cast and
which one was constantly asking you for
spoilers
um
my seven-year-old nephew then
six or five five to six yeah he's been
obsessed with marvel since he was like
three
so really young but yeah he's been and i
i made the mistake of telling him a few
things and then he told my brother and
my brother is really pissed off so now
i'm just like
no more
i should have known you know like poor
guy is like six
i was gonna i don't think five-year-olds
can hold uh secrets i learned i learned
my lesson
um you obviously have never made a
marvel property until now like this big
huge thing what ended up being something
that like really surprised you about
working with them and you know making a
show like moon night
how collaborative everything is it felt
like we were developing a play many
times because we
the way we did it was we um on any
sunday we could get where no one was
filming we would go over
every episode like every episode had a
day where we'd work on it for six hours
and read through it every anytime we
came found a hole or something didn't
make sense that we bumped on we we tried
to really get in there and we there were
no shortcuts taken which i really
appreciate but that also opened the door
to like on the day of filming we'd work
on scenes and if something didn't make
sense and it's kind of like you you want
to you want to prepare in advance and
this project was like no you're not
preparing you just kind of have to know
who your character is and then dive in
was that when on the sundays you're
specifically talking about is that you
with even an oscar is it with the
directors who exactly is getting
together that would be everyone from
ethan oscar muhammad diab his wife um
who's also a producer greg curtis uh
aaron and justin
um yeah
it's a big group big group
um oh and sorry sorry and the two
writers so we'd have like
uh
peter or sauber with us and
um
at times different writers would like
pop in if they had written or
collaborated on that piece before
i've seen the four of the six episodes
and i can't say anything because i don't
want to ruin it for people so i'll ask
you what are you most excited for
audiences to actually see in the show
i'm so excited for audiences to see the
backdrop of egypt but also
mainly
you know
the whole mental health aspect of it and
to see how
oscar goes about it and moon knight and
how it's manifested through the
supernatural and then what all what it
all culminates to in episode four
yeah i wish i could talk specifically
yeah
one one of the other things is that it's
the production design on the show is
incredible
some of the sets that i was watching i'm
like this is really impressive yeah we
look amazing what was it like actually
seeing these things for the first time
and working in these environments
our set designer stefania was incredible
and put so much of her heart into
everything like she is an artist
and
like a mad scientist that made
everything
super and she really works with muhammad
because muhammad wanted that specific
specificity also on each in on egypt um
and it felt like we were in egypt like i
can't say i know what it's like to be
inside um a pyramid you know what i mean
but i can say i know what it's like to
be in egypt and that it really felt like
being in egypt i don't know if i just
gave away a spoiler but um
no i i that's okay no one's going to get
mad about that okay
um and so
as an actor that's like a dream you know
to be able to work off of that kind of
specificity
but also it's just a testament to how
everyone really put their heart and soul
and it made you just want to equally
give that much on that note i gotta stop
i'm just gonna say congrats i know thank
you so much and good luck with the rest
of your speed dating thank you